السيد الرئيس العظ المق ان عداء بين
اسرائيل
وحماس الحق ضررا واذ كبيرين على كل من
الفلسطينيين والاسرائيليين ولكن فهم
هذا هذا الوضع ينبغي
ان لا يجعلنا ننسى ما قامت به حماس في
قطاع غزه عندما انسحبت حماس سحبت كل
قواتها ومدنها من غزه في عام
2005 تركت منطقه
ساحليه كان يمكن ان تصبح قصه نجاح
اقتصاديه وسياسيه
ولكن عناصر حماس العنيفه استولت على
الاداره واستولت على السلطه وخلال 16 عاما
من حكمها قامت بتهريب كميه كبيره من
الاسلحه وحولت الملايين من المساعدات
الاجنبيه ليس لبنا لبناء المدارس
والمستشفيات والملاجئ لحمايه مواطنيها
وشعبها من الهجمات
لكن استخدمت ل تحويل كل البنى التحتيه
المدنيه الى اكبر
مواقع والاكثر تحصينا في حرب المدن في
العالم المذهل ان محام ان
محامي
المدعيه وكانهم لا يدركون الدمار
الكبير
المحزن ان معاناه المدنيين في الحروب لا
تقتصر فقط على
غزه غير الامر غير المسبوق هو درجه تحصين
حماس وتحسنها داخل صفوف المدنيين وجعل
المدنيين الفلسطينيين يعادون وذلك جزءا من
استراتيجيتها اسرائيل وبشكل حماس وبشكل
منهجي قامت
ب
زرع عناصرها ومراكزها في صفف المدنين وبنت
شبكه غير مسبوقه من الانفاق لمقاتليها
وقادتها بطول مئات الكيلومترات
في انحاء قطاع غز مع الكثير من المداخل
وال فتوحات هذه الانفاق مخبه في المدارس
والمساجد وال حتى المستشفيات اذا هذا ليس
تكتيك كان اعتياديا
هذا هذه منهجيه حرب ممنهجه وتهدف الى قتل
المدنيين واطلاق را اطلاق الصواريخ بشكل
عشوائي واستخدام المدنيين وبشكل منهجي
كدروع بشريه كذلك سرقه
ونهب المستلزمات والامدادات ما يتسبب
بمعاناه المدني وذلك تستخدم تلك المواد
لتغذيه ان معاناه الفلسطينين
والاسرائيليين هي وقبل كل شيء نتيجه لهذه
الاستراتيجيه
المقيته ان ثمن فشل حماس في حمايه مدنها
والتضحيه بهم من اجل من اجل منافع وفوائد
بروجيه وعسكريه
وكذلك واذا ما تخلت حماس عن تلك
الاستراتيجيه واطلقت
سراح رهائن فان القتال والعنف سيتوقف
وينتهي السيده الرئيس الاعضاء
المقرون هنالك الكثير من المغالطات في
الدعوه المقدمه ولكن
سنبن ان هنالك واحده تسمو على الكل في
القضيه قضيه يقولون انه
ليس
يقولون انه ليس هنالك قتال يتم بين طرفين
وان قيل للمحكمه
وحدث حدثوا المحكمه واقبر المحكمه عن
الدمار الهائل الذي طال الاماكن ولكن لم
يخبر المحكمه بان معظم تلك المنشات
والمرافق تم تدميرها لانها فخخ من قبل
حماس كذلك استخدام المرافق المدنيه والبنى
التحتيه المدنيه
كمواقع اخفاء مقاتلين عدد المباني
التي التي اصيبت بالالاف الصواريخ التي
ظلت
طريقها الحديث عن 20 ال ضحيه
وهه احصاءات معلومات غير موثقه مصدرها
حماس وهي مصدر غير موثوق
البت كل ضحيه مدنيه في هذا النزاع هي
ماساه ان انيه تتطلب
تعاطفنا ولكن المحكمه لم تخبر عدد الالاف
من الضحايا معظمهم من المقاتلين وكم عدد
الذين قتلوا على يد مقاتلي حماس وعدد
المدنيين الذين شاركوا في الاعمال
القتاليه
وكذلك المحكمه
ايضا
طلعت على الوضع الانساني المتردي ولكن لم
تخبر المحكمه عن نهب المساعدات الانسانيه
ولا جهود اسرائيل المتعلقه بالحد من الضرر
والاذى الذي يلحق بالمدنيين وذلك من خلال
تمكين وصول المساعدات وتوفير الرعايه
للمصابين المدعيه ظللت الحقائق في غزه
ولكن صورت وكان حماس وازدرائها لحياه
الانسان غير موجوده باعتبارها سببا رئيسيا
لتلك الحقائق على الارض
حماس وفقا للتقديرات لديها 3 ال
مقاتل
و يشارك في صفوفها اطفال دون سن ال 15 عش
ولكن وفقا لروايه جنوب افريقيا فان هؤلاء
جميعهم اختفوا ليس هنالك متفجرات في
المساجد المدارس و في غرف النوم ولا
تستخدم سيارات الاسعاف لنقل المقاتلين ولا
مقاتلين يرتدون ملابس
مدنيه ولا اطلاق نار
من منازل مدنيين ولا حتى المناطق
الامنه وكان اسرائيل هي فقط التي تتصرف في
غزه الجهه المدعيه تطلب من المحكمه
ان
تحول هذا النزاع بين
دوله وفصيل
مارقه الى جيش يحارب مدنيين ولكنهم لم
يقدموا عدسه لهذه المحكمه
ولكن ما قام به
هوطا يحجب
ابصارهم
اسرائيل ملتزمه كما ينبغي
بالقانون الدولي ولكنها تفعل ذلك في
مواجهه حماس التي لا تحترم
القانون هي ترد ولكي تثبت الانسانيه
ولكنها تفعل ذلك في مواجهه انعدام
الانسانيه لدى حماس وكما
تقدم المحامي فان ذلك
هو سياسه
الدوله هناك ايضا تعبير عن قيم اسرائيل
الاساسيه وهناك اجراءات يتم اتخاذها من
اجل الحد من الاضرار ضد المدنيين لكنها
ظروف حرب اوجدتها حماس ومن غير المقبول
ان
دوله تصرف بهذه الطريقه وفي مثل هذه
الظروف توصف وتتهم بانها تقوم بعمل اباده
جماعيه ان المكون الرئيسي للاباده هو نيه
القضاء القضاء على شعب جزئيا او كليا ولكن
ما تريده اسرائيل في غزه هو ليس القضاء
على شعب ولكن لحمايه شعب شعب غزه الذين هم
معرضون للهجوم في جبهات عديده وتفعل ذلك
طبقا للقانون بالرغم من انها تواجه عدوا
شديدا لا يحترم
القانون هدف اسرائيل المشروع في غزه واضح
من قبل رئيس الوزراء ووزير الدفاع وجميع
اعضاء مجلس الحرب وكما قال رئيس الوزراء
هذا الاسبوع اسرائيل
يحارب ارهابي حماس وليس شعب غزه وتريد ان
تضمن ان غزه تتوقف عن كونها مصدرا لاطلاق
الهجمات على
اسرائيل وتحتاج الى ان ولا تريد ايضا وليس
لها نيه ان تعيد احتلال غزه انها تريد ان
توجد مستقبلا افضل لفلسطينيين
والاسرائيليين حتى يعيش الجميع في سلام
وفي ازدهار
ومع الفلسطينيين يمكنهم
ان يديروا شؤون انفسهم ولكن ليس ان يهددوا
اسرائيل اذا كان هناك تهديد وخطر انساني
للمدنيين في في غزه
فانه يعود الى كونهم يعيشون تحت حكم جماعه
ارهابيه لا تعطي قيمه لحياتهم ولا
ازدهاره حماس ووكلائها وداعموه هم الذين
يتسببون في
ذلك
ولا لا توجد الظروف للتقدم نحو سلام وامن
وازدهار في
المنطقه اسرائيل تحارب حماس وليس شعب
الفلسطيني لكي تتاكد من عدم نجاح حماس في
تحقيق
اهدافها ولا يمكن ان في هذه الظروف ان
يكون هناك تهمه
خاطئه اكثر من اتهام اسرائيل بانها تنوي
القيام باباده
جماعيه وبشكل خاص هذه الاجراءات
الاحترازيه التي تطالب بها جنوب
افريقيا سيده الرئيس اعضاء المحكمه
الموقرين معاهده الاباده
[موسيقى]
الجماعيه جاءت بعد محرقه اليهود وهي ترمي
الى عدم تكرر ذلك
ابدا اذا كانت كلمه اباده يحط من معناها
وقدرها الى هذا المستوى اذا امكن اتخاذ
تدابير احترازيه فان معاهده تصبح
دون فحوى او مائده وسوف يتم الاختفاء وراء
المدنيين ولل المحافظه على قيمه
هذه
المعاهده
و معناها فاننا نطالب بان يتم رفض هذا
الطلب
لانه غير معتمد ولانه يهدف الى حرمان
اسرائيل من حقها في الدفاع عن نفسها من
هجوم ارهابي غير مسبوق
ولتحرير 136 رهينه الذين لا
يزالون في قبضه حماس اشكركم واطلب منكم